new at news today the convention  business celebrates a major  milestone the return of trade shows  finally here in town  world of concrete opened just a few  hours ago it is the first  major convention to use the billion  dollar las vegas convention center's new  west hall that expansion  it's also the nation's biggest trade  show to happen since the pandemic  started  now for us here at home that means  nearly 50 thousand workers are back  governor steve sisolak was on hand there  this morning to welcome convention goers  this convention reinvigorates our  commitment to being bold  and how we envision the future of  infrastructure and the recovery of our  state  and this is only the beginning lbcva  says the convention industry  generated about 11 billion dollars a  year before the pandemic and economic  impact that's expected to grow to 14  billion  after this expansion